pillow
we are celebrating the new rom-com which
just could not be more fantastic and
epic Bros all day long and we've got
more guests to add to the Bros party now
here are some fun facts about them one
of them has danced with President Obama
uh-huh another one had a childhood crush
on Jason Bateman
and one of them was just sampled by
Beyonce
they're part of the entirely
lgbtq plus cast of bros please welcome
to
Tia oh my gosh okay before we jump into
the movie Beyonce sampled you you're in
her new amazing record yeah
I am on cozy it's song two on the
Renaissance album and I I'm so I'm blown
away when you got into Bros
um is it true that maybe you thought
next to you was Stanley Tucci this is
not Stanley too right here
and then I started acting and she went
up no it's not him is it true that you
had a crush on Jason Bateman when you
were younger yeah I'm not I'm not mad
about it and I love it um
I've met him before so now he's going to
find this out but but yes you know I was
a child of Television so I was watching
Silver Spoons I was on the set of Silver
Spoons then you met my crush I did talk
about me
I just thought he was so funny and his
humor was already on point then and I
just yeah that was my first crush well
Miss Lawrence you sing You Dance you act
but you used to play football I played
football when I was little yeah you know
I went through that phase where my
parents went through that phase of they
could see the whole Queen and me and
they would try to do everything they
could to get it out so typically parents
um they they send their little boys to
like football camps and all that kind of
it didn't work and actually what it did
was made me have a stronger attraction
to men especially
but I was very good at it because I'm
gonna be good at anything that I do
um Jim you are an academy award-winning
writer for The Descendants everybody
you and your writing partner Matt Faxon
I I mean literally you're some of the
most important screenwriters in
Hollywood telling some of the best
stories let me put my hair back
you are you know you're playing an actor
in this but really when it comes to like
Hollywood you guys are like the biggest
writers and this is a film about
storytelling yeah and I think this movie
is so grounded in that it's not
alienating people it's talking about
also history which you can't change it's
inarguable so let's tell these stories
yes I I think what is admirable what
Billy and along with Nick writing it
when a writer and performer allows
themselves to write some very hard
truths and and showing themselves and
vulnerable to us it really Taps into and
brings us into his character as he's
talking about am I lovable uh Will I Be
Loved this is these are Universal things
when we look for someone to to follow in
love with we know that heartbreak might
be on the other side of that but that's
the vulnerability I think it's in this
movie that makes it much more Universal
you know I agree and that's so well put
and I just I'm such an advocate for this
film and I love it so much and as
someone who has been a lifelong Advocate
I've marched I've voted I was raised in
West Hollywood in 1975.
I feel like there's also a new
generation and a new sort of Runway
where even someone like me feels like in
like rapid gotcha moment like even I
could get this wrong because we are also
trying to come up with new language new
pronouns none of us want to get it wrong
none of us want to say the wrong thing
do the wrong thing and your film is like
so much about history and humanity and
storytelling and you just don't push
anyone away which is so extraordinary
yeah well even I can get it wrong like
I'm a trans woman and I'm still learning
like I'm full
I will be 45 years old on October 22nd
thank you Mom I'm 47.
and so you know I'm still learning like
I am still learning the proper pronouns
and the proper you know way to address
people and anytime that I'm in a
a situation where I don't know I just
simply ask yeah but it does get it it's
a lot right because a lot of it is is
all new I've just as of the last couple
years decided to fully embrace it and
welcome it only because it is causing a
lot of conversations to be had and it's
causing a lot of
um majority of society to be really
inquisitive about who we are and we've
never had that before either right I
couldn't agree more yeah and we've never
had that before and
what this movie does to your point it
serves as a safe space because we have
to learn to be patient with each other
you know we are literally bringing two
strangers of cultures together meaning
the straight community and the gay
community and we're bringing them
together as as strangers so it's okay
for a reintroduction yeah I love that
like I I feel that this movie does not
alienate or make you feel judged or
right or wrong how did you guys manage
to do that because it's it's so much
more about Humanity yeah rather than
this is how you do it this is how you
shouldn't do it well I think what was so
genius about the way the movie was cast
I think
um Nick and Billy were very
um intentional about casting every type
of person that represents the lgbtqia
community and so when you give everybody
the same playing field to be themselves
and to get their character's point of
view across I think you kind to get rid
of all of those questioning moments
about will I say the right thing what I
don't because everybody is there to get
their point of view their perspectives
and what they offer and lend to society
out it's really bone chillingly
beautiful there's so much poetry in this
film as well as advocacy and teaching
everybody and welcoming them in you guys
just bridge that so well thank you thank
you thank you thank you well
um we're gonna go to a quick commercial
break but coming up I want to get them
to spill some spicy stories um with a
round of brose or Rose I love this game
[Music]